françoise arpaillange parcours ses rangs
elle est dans son élément
cette viticultrice de pernand
vergelesses n'aurais jamais imaginé
qu'elle puisse redouter un jour de l'est
sillonnaient et pourtant c'est ce qui
lui est arrivé au lendemain d'une nuit
cauchemardesque
le 27 avril 2016 un spectacle de
désolation l'attend quelques heures le
gel l'a privé de 70% de sa récolte un
coup dur financier que françois je ne
peux pas encore chiffrée mais elle en
connaît déjà le prix psychologique
j'ai passé une étape très très durs et
maintenant quand je suis un ennemi bin
je pense pas quand est-ce que je me
replonge dans l'eau ce qui nous est
arrivé c'est quand je descends mal à
cap-chat genre décembre à la cas avec
que je vois mais nombre de fûts et je me
dise pas moi si je me suis trompé genre
il ya là quelque part ailleurs c'est pas
possible je me juge a gelé recompte sont
bien tout cela printemps 2016 un épisode
de gel c'est vers s'abat sur toute la
bourgogne
rebelote en avril 2010 est dans l'yonne
ces deux dernières années le sort s'est
acharné sur le vignoble
c'est pour lutter contre ce fléau à
répétition que marie-guite dufay la
présidente de la région est venu
annoncer à la profession le déblocage de
crédits
objectif définir les équipements les
plus pertinents grâce à une étude puis
les co financé je voudrais qu'on avance
pragmatiquement mais que demain à côté
des aides financières de compensation
que l'on peut amener on puisse avoir des
dispositif pérenne qui sécurise les
viticulteurs je crois que cette fois ci
on n'est pas dans le symbole on est
vraiment on va tous nous on va arriver
dans l'opérationnel la terre professions
intermédiaires de sa commission
technique va également participer pour
la pour répertorier tous et tous ses
moyens de lutte
une fois qu'on les aura répertoriés et
qu'on va regarder ceux qui sont
intéressants en fonction de la
topographie de chaque de chaque vignoble
on pourra commencer à mettre en place
une un programme d'investissement
l'exécutif régional espère mettre en
place de façon expérimentale
les premiers équipements anti gel en
avril 2010 8,1 mois d'avril que
françoise et bien d'autres viticulteurs
bourguignons redoutent désormais